[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial del debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález el tráfico de
drogas sigue siendo un negocio muy
lucrativo para la región de américa
latina' demos un vistazo a algunas
cifras simplemente para ponerlos en
contexto se estima que el narcotráfico
genera entre 80.000 y 90.000 millones de
dólares anuales en ganancias sólo en el
continente americano unas 50 millones de
personas consumen cocaína heroína y otro
tipo de sustancias ilegales los flujos
ilícitos relacionados con las drogas
afectan principalmente al sistema
financiero y a países como eeuu méxico y
colombia
en los últimos años varios países de
américa latina como méxico colombia perú
entre otros pasaron de ser países de
producción o de tránsito hacia el países
de consumo con crecientes mercados
internos que también comienzan a
preocupar a las autoridades locales la
pregunta es o tal vez la pregunta que se
han venido haciendo muchos a lo largo de
los últimos años es si fallo la lucha
contra las drogas sigue sin tener una
respuesta muy clara esta pregunta qué
hacer para combatir este gigantesco
negocio mundial que cada vez más crece y
se expande crece que va también de la
mano de la corrupción de la pobreza y de
la violencia va creciendo y se va
expandiendo y va albergando diferentes
áreas es una amenaza múltiple y que
amenaza a las democracias de américa
latina- también la institucionalidad y
el poder de los estados la lucha contra
el narcotráfico es nuestro tema de
análisis en este especial del debate de
france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a francisco tú me él es
miembro del comité de asesores del
informe mundial sobre las drogas de las
naciones unidas también de la academia
colombiana de ciencias económicas
también está con nosotros alberto
otárola peñaranda él es abogado
constitucionalista y miembro de la junta
internacional de fiscalización de
estupefacientes él se conecta desde la
ciudad de lima en perú y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 nos acompaña a
césar para es internacionalista docente
de la facultad de finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales de la
universidad externado que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden ser parte de este debate con
todos los comentarios y las preguntas
que ustedes tengan sobre este tema lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter les recuerdo la
cuenta es arroba france24
s arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal y también les recuerdo la
etiqueta que es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas damos inicio entonces al
debate comienzo con francisco
preguntándole como punto de partida para
esta discusión este análisis
si esta industria del narcotráfico a
nivel de américa latina' a nivel del
continente americano es imparable se
está saliendo de control de las manos de
las autoridades como lo vio usted
sí
pero eso ha sido ya por 40 años
es decir el problema fundamental es que
realmente
i
no hay una indica que 60 mente
en una de extensión
que permitan atacar las raíces reales
del libro
es decir la política actual
ya por muchísimo tiempo ha sido basada
en la fuerza y el temor para sanción
pero
el problema es que la droga no son en
en general en la sociedad actual hay una
cantidad de dificultad en muchos estados
que no pueden generar lealtad y
confianza de sus ciudadanos y las
sociedades están totalmente seguridades
y por eso hay corrupción hay violencia y
francés al drogas hay exportaciones
ilegales
de una cantidad de productos de mercados
informales etcétera entonces
las drogas son una rama
de las actividades criminales que son
rentables
y cuando uno se enfoca en la lucha hacia
esa rama lo más que puede lograr es que
haya desplazamientos de las fuentes por
ejemplo está mi amigo el mundo veneranda
y perdona se presentaron a tener anda y
él sabe que perú por el mayor punto de
cocaína claro por eso se dispuso al club
alberto
misma la misma pregunta para el inicio a
este debate para este punto de partida
esto es una industria imparable se le
está saliendo de control a las
autoridades dados los números que
presentaba yo al inicio del programa y
otros hechos que hemos visto a lo largo
de este año 2021 que ya los vamos a
mencionar aquí en el debate cuál es su
opinión
bueno un saludo profesor tube y muchas
gracias por la entrevista yo creo que el
fenómeno
ha mutado pero sigue siendo el mismo
tiene una alta rentabilidad y
especialmente luego de la pandemia del
cob y no se han producido digamos tres
situaciones que hemos identificado
perfectamente en la jife y que guardan
relación con el fenómeno de profesor
turbia relataba en primer lugar se ha
producido por ejemplo una disminución de
la disponibilidad
de drogas y un aumento de los precios
los organismos de control y nacionales
de otros fenómenos que venimos
observando en todos los países
especialmente en los de centro y
sudamérica han tenido que variar
su ámbito de acción hacia la atención de
la emergencia de cubit digamos dejando
en segundo plano la intervención y la
interdicción el tráfico ilícito de
drogas y en tercer lugar es algo que
venimos estudiando en jefe se ha
producido un cambio en el modus operandi
de las organizaciones internacionales de
tráfico de drogas es decir son nuevas
rutas
se ha producido lo que se llama la
internet y es el acceso a internet a la
red oscura que no es tan oscura porque
cualquier persona en este momento puede
gestionar un
medicamento entre comillas prohibido con
alto dos dosis de opiáceos por el
internet entonces todo esto ha
configurado no se ha roto un nuevo
modelo de negocio que en esencia en
esencia tiene la misma base decir mucha
corrupción una alta ineficiencia de los
órganos del estado y sobre todo un
exceso una falta de digamos adecuación
de los organismos internacionales para
entender ese proceso yo creo que tenemos
que cambiar todos sobre todo con ciertos
quienes tienen los enfoques que han sido
desplazados por la propia realidad claro
hoy aquí en el estudio de france 24 para
terminar esta primera ronda de punto de
partida se zarpa es está con nosotros
pensar su opinión sobre este tema es una
industria imparable que continúa
creciendo y bueno como lo han dicho los
otros dos invitados que se conocen los
factores se conocen las causas pero no
hay la detenga pues es sin parar en la
medida en que hay una una demanda que es
muy dinámica es decir si hay mucha gente
que está consumiendo drogas en el mundo
y es imparable en la medida en que hay
una oferta también que es muy dinámica y
que se adapta muy bien muy rápidamente a
las diferentes condiciones que van
cambiando por la acción de los estados o
por la misma preferencia de los
consumidores en ese sentido si es
imparable pero hay ejemplos en otras
regiones del mundo en las que se ha
eliminado prácticamente por completo la
producción por ejemplo de la planta que
es la materia prima para la producción
en el caso de éxito que uno siempre
utiliza en las clases cuando está
hablando de este tema es tailandia
tailandia era uno de los principales
productores de amapola para la
producción de opio de heroína y hoy en
día ya no lo es en un lapso
relativamente corto de unos 30 años en
tailandia desapareció si lo vemos a
nivel regional aquí en américa latina
bolivia y sobre todo pero eran los
grandes productores tanto de coca como
de cocaína
ya no lo son colombia era el país que
controlaba la mayor parte si no la
totalidad de la exportación y del
tráfico de cocaína hoy en día ya no lo
es pero decir eso es un fenómeno que va
mutando con el tiempo y que se va
desplazando hoy ante y esto tiene un
nombre del efecto globo el efecto
cucaracha etcétera etcétera pero digamos
es un fenómeno frente al que hay
sociedades que sí han podido hacer algo
y frente al que si se ha logrado al
menos desplazar el fenómeno y exportarlo
es decir dárselo a otros a otros países
a otras sociedades césar usted menciona
el caso de tailandia como lo logro
tailandia que política se implementó que
hizo este país del sureste asiático para
compartir en combatir esto básicamente
fue un programa de largo plazo de largo
plazo además por las condiciones propias
de tailandia es que entre la cndh ya hay
una hay una monarquía muy estable y que
vas abajo digamos la política del danés
es muy inestable pero la monarquía es
una institución estable y prácticamente
intocable y fue la propia monarquía la
que auspició el programa de eliminación
de cultivos y lo que hicieron pues
un poco siguiendo el manual si me
permiten la expresión de qué hacer para
lograr un desarrollo rural integrado de
primero la erradicación de los cultivos
luego la sustitución luego la creación
de una serie de servicios de
infraestructura soy yo hoy en día es
impresionante realmente las imágenes de
personas que antes estaban que eran
utilizadas para la producción de amapola
y hoy en día son bosques por ejemplo
nuevos que recuperados que además se
recuperan además tailandés un país por
ejemplo en términos climáticos e incluso
hasta cierto punto políticos similares a
colombia no es un país tropical es un
país la región a la que se producirá la
amapola era principalmente
montañosa hubo grupos guerrilleros allí
y gracias a este programa de largo
aliento estamos hablando de programas de
15 20 30 años se logró eliminar el
problema en tailandia no en el mundo la
agresividad y otras regiones donde se
sigue produciendo amapola para la
producción de opio y heroína pero en
tailandia desapareció en perú lo tenemos
cerca aquí hoy hoy en día la situación
es muy diferente a lo que fue en los
años 80 o en bolivia e incluso en
colombia la situación también ha
cambiado
mira la acerca un poco la lente y
empieza a ver regiones por regiones o
incluso municipios por los municipios en
el caso colombiano hacemos como eso
también acá me ha cambiado poco a poco
pues precisamente en ese cambio llama la
atención alberto alberto que nos
acompaña desde la ciudad de lima en perú
como países que anteriormente no tenían
nada que ver con este negocio o que
simplemente eran países por donde
pasaban
digamos países de tránsito de todas
estas rutas para llevar en el
narcotráfico a
principalmente eeuu que sería digamos
uno de los mercados principales en el
continente americano le han dado paso a
que países como por ejemplo ecuador o
costa rica hayan entrado ahora a ser
parte de las redes de los
narcotraficantes y ya no sean
simplemente puntos de paso sino que son
países donde hay
alianzas nexos con grupos
delincuenciales a nivel local esto
muestra que se extiende en la región que
ya no deja de ser que ya deja de ser un
tema solamente de colombia perú bolivia
que eran los que producían sino que se
va extendiendo y va abrir nuevos
mercados que dice usted a alberto
no solamente en nuevos mercados sino
digamos nuevos usos y costumbres por
ejemplo en américa del sur están
aumentando la fabricación y la presencia
de drogas sintéticas especialmente el
chile en ecuador y en brasil se prevé
que la crisis económica causada por la
lengua 19 hará que las modalidades de
consumo y tráfico de drogas se orienten
hacia sustancias más baratas y adictivas
en chile el observatorio chileno drogas
observaba una posible expansión del
mercado ilícito de drogas sintéticas es
cierto que son mucho más baratas son
menos son más seguras para los
traficantes y notoriamente son más
rentables entonces todo este problema ha
generado con los tres únicos países en
el mundo que producen cocaína que son
bolivia perú y colombia y que
ciertamente como lo ha dicho la persona
que antes de meterse en la palabra
aplicaron sobre todo perú y bolivia el
modelo que se llama desarrollo
alternativo integral y sostenible esto
ha sido rebasado por la demanda mundial
es decir estamos en el hemos regresado
al típico modelo no sé de demanda y
oferta que se va acentuando y que
inclusive tiene rutas que antes eran
impensables no están yendo en este
momento por ejemplo avioneta saliendo de
brasil y ando mauritania en el áfrica
llevando cocaína y cargada de cocaína
así que los que eran productores o de
tránsito se han vuelto consumidores y
esto se ha acentuado lo repito en chile
en uruguay y también en argentina ahora
vamos a hablar de esos países
consumidores de la región de américa
latina le pregunto francisco la gran
pregunta que hemos venido tratando de
resolver a lo largo de estos años el
modelo entonces de la lucha contra las
drogas fracasó esta lucha en algunos
países directa armada a través de los
ejércitos locales y fracasó como tal y
es momento de implementar una nueva
estrategia que piensa usted
bueno primero en la guerra contra las
drogas
hay que definirla
decir la guerra contra las drogas surgió
en eeuu y fue una guerra interna dentro
de eeuu no fue una guerra externa
el problema externo en eeuu
un país como colombia exportaba cocaína
y estados unidos por ser tienen todo el
derecho a prohibir la entrada de cocaína
y eso se hizo de antes de las
convenciones eso fue antes de
under the bridge a nixon ronald reagan
etcétera
al hablar de lucha contra las drogas
precisamente lo que se enfatiza en la
fuerza
y no el entendimiento la comprensión de
lo que realmente es el problema
nosotros tenemos un problema fundamental
de falta de la nación de identidad
nacional
lo cual produce estados muy débiles
colombiana muy parecida a afganistán
ambos países pareciera que tuvieran uno
una patente para controlar el mercado
mundial en la producción de heroína y el
otro de cocaína
y lo que hay en la mente en ambos es una
falta de control territorial
una desigualdad de la gente bastante
alta una falta de
organizaciones sociales
que respondan al estado que colaboren
con el estado
es economía es cierto que ha perdido el
control de los mercados de cocaína
en el exterior pero si no se va a
desplazar el cultivo de colombia
pero quisiera matizar un poco el caso de
tailandia porque sí es cierto que ellos
resolvieron el problema
de el opio y la heroína
pero mucha de la gente que estaba allí
especialmente lo sea étnicamente chinos
están
involucrados
profundamente en el mercado de
anfetaminas entonces el lincoln desplaza
y francisco
si paso acá al estudio de france 24 a
preguntarle a césar francisco menciona
unos aspectos que creo que son comunes
para todos los países de la región y es
que hay pobreza hay desigualdad
corrupción porque no empezar a atacar
este problema desde ahí
porque es muy difícil decir son los
grandes problemas de los países
latinoamericanos de la gran mayoría de
los países latinoamericanos y de otras
regiones también son son problemas
estructurales que se solucionan si
tenemos suerte al cabo de una generación
sino son problemas que se solucionarán
después de dos o tres generaciones no
obtendríamos no sé tal vez hay
excepciones a esto en otras regiones
corea del sur o taiwán o bueno países
que han sido que han tenido un
crecimiento rápido y desarrollo
económico rápido pero realmente estamos
hablando de problemas estructurales y
eso también me lleva a algo que creo que
hay que tener claro aquí y es lo que
llamamos la guerra al narcotráfico la
guerra contra las drogas cuál es el
costo que estamos dispuestos a pagar
como sociedad por eliminar el problema
digámoslo así no en américa latina y
volviendo a los ejemplos de países que
han logrado sacar al narcotráfico
digamos de su territorio
tenemos dos ejemplos claros donde
desapareció por completo chile y cuba
cada país en el momento en el que llegó
la dictadura un chile la dictadura de
augusto pinochet al cabo de unos años ya
no había narcotráfico en chile cuando
chile era uno de los centros principales
que controlaban tráfico de drogas en
esta parte del mundo y cuba con la
llegada de castro de fidel castro y la
dictadura cubana al cabo de unos años el
narcotráfico había desaparecido de cuba
la pregunta es por supuesto cuál fue el
costo que creo que sospechamos cuál es
la respuesta y si como sociedad estamos
dispuestos a pagar un costo similar
alberto en la ciudad de lima ese costo y
esa capacidad que tengan los países o
los gobiernos para dar respuesta a estas
situaciones
puede ser muy alto pero pero eso me
lleva también a preguntarme
y le trasladó la pregunta usted que es
el conocedor del tema que tan permeado
está el narcotráfico y los cárteles a
nivel político a nivel de los gobiernos
de américa latina
que permita mantenerse allí que les
permita a ambas partes sostenerse unos a
otros para garantizarse protección y
durabilidad
pero que el narcotráfico es
transfronterizo no tiene nacionalidades
y fíjense yo me permitiría una
descripción en blanco y negro del
problema en los países especialmente la
región andina el campesino cocalero
pobre es el eslabón más débil de la
cadena del narcotráfico
entonces ha habido procesos por ejemplo
yo recibí este proceso en el perú
durante tres años y lo que es esa cosa
se logró sacar de la pobreza a más de un
millón de personas aplicando el
desarrollo alternativo integral y
sostenible en la zona de monzón dándoles
infraestructura carreteras créditos
bancarios títulos de propiedad puentes
para elevar el valor de sus productos
alternar y volver son básicamente en el
juego el cacao y el café para que tengan
un mayor valor de mercado que el acoge
el mercado internacional yo creo que es
digamos es el círculo virtuoso que a
full sea nada en tailandia que ha
funcionado en el perú que entiendo o
mucha dificultad está tratando de que
funcione funciones en colombia así que
me parece que al que hay que proteger
son las familias que son
obligada por el narcotráfico y que
sirven de base para esta inmensa
producción tanto en el perú como el
colombiano fíjese pero está llegando ya
casi a las 90.000 hectáreas de coca y
colombia está en 120.000 más o menos lo
mismo que bolivia es decir que estamos
la pandemia nos ha convertido en
naciones que moore digamos multiplicado
en la producción de coca hoja de coca
ilegal y los campesinos siguen pobres de
ser quienes la producen y les son los
pilotados por narcotráfico siguen siendo
pobres ese será el reto los estados y
creo que también es el gran reto los
organismos internacionales como es un
reto que ha venido a lo largo de los
años pero tal parece que los países no
logran dar respuesta a estas diferencias
sociales
a
estas zonas alejadas de los grandes
centros urbanos en américa latina' que
por lo general son zonas muy aisladas
empobrecidas con muchas dificultades
para los habitantes allí en estas
regiones leyendo algunos de los reportes
el señor francisco algunos de los
reportes informes que hay sobre el
consumo y el narcotráfico en la región
de américa latina'
sugerían que una de las formas para
empezar a combatir esta industria
internacional que está entrelazada en
los cinco continentes
sería atacar el lavado de dinero y las
instituciones financieras que están
implicadas o metidas en este negocio
antes que continuar con este tipo de
luchas
armadas digámoslo así en los territorios
de países como colombia o perú o bolivia
el lavado de dinero se está convirtiendo
entonces de pronto en el punto de
partida para una nueva lucha como lo ve
usted
es decir eso se empezó al tratar de
hacer ya hace mucho tiempo que allí hay
debe estar los fundamentales que surgen
de un sistema
del mercado
que está en señal para proteger la
propiedad no para expropiar cuando se
habla de atacar el lavado se habla de
expropiación y administrar una cantidad
de actores
a muchos de ellos
porque estamos
financiero
suena
puede ser necesario hacer
para resultar
eso no va a poder identificar
en muchos en todos nuestros países donde
tenemos
una debilidad profunda
del
derecho de propiedad no pasa en colombia
pase profundo posible seleccionar
los derechos de propiedad de surjan del
narcotráfico de agrado de la corrupción
encargan de los que simplemente salen de
la
calidad del sistema
francisco en cada se dan cuenta que yo
le quiero dos generaciones más claro en
los colegios acá
por eso es que insisto que no podemos
seguir con la escucha
de que atacar los problemas
estructurales es muy difícil y que toma
mucho tiempo
si a largo plazo todos están muertos así
es que no vamos a resolver el problema
claro francisco en el caso de colombia
y llevó a avanzar con otros temas que
tengo sobre la sobre la mesa para
discutir
césar acá en el estudio
ya lo hablábamos con francisco el lavado
de dinero puede ser un punto para
empezar a atacar esto este este mal del
narcotráfico pero que hay de la
legalización del uso y el consumo de las
drogas en países como por ejemplo
uruguay han empezado a producir y
también a
permitir el consumo controlado de
marihuana por ejemplo es la legalización
tal vez uno de los caminos que podamos
dar en un futuro pues yo creo que es el
camino que ya empezamos a transitar pero
antes de eso yo creo que vale la pena si
la la prohibición no fue un capricho no
surgió de la nada no surge un problema
grave que habían a finales del siglo 19
comienzos del siglo 20 de consumo muy
localizado sobre todo en china pero pues
que se había extendido con la diáspora
china a otras partes del mundo entonces
realmente digamos frente a eso una de
las medidas que se descubrió en ese
momento tienen diseñar la política fue
la prohibición y lamentablemente tuvo
mucho éxito tanto que se convirtió en la
política internacional la política
mundial hoy en día hemos visto que ya
desde hace unos buenos años se está
empezando a recorrer a transitar el
camino de la legalización no lo tal vez
los primeros casos fueron algunos
estados de eeuu que legalizaron la
marihuana con uso medicinal
y después de unos años empezó la
legalización para uso recreativo y el
ejemplo de países completos que si no me
falla la memoria tal vez tenemos 2
uruguay y canadá es el otro país como
como entidad política
independiente completa digámoslo así que
ha legalizado entonces yo creo que ya
estamos ya estamos recorriendo ese
camino y la verdad si les soy sincero a
mí me resulta un poco un poco extraño
obviamente con todo el contexto y la
historia y como nos dedicamos a este
tema pues sabemos de dónde viene la
provisión pero realmente a mí me parece
exótico que en pleno siglo 21 2021
finalizando el 2021 estemos viendo o
haya gente que esté discutiendo si
legalizamos la marihuana o no la
legalizan vos pico porque sabemos que la
marihuana no es una droga
particularmente fuerte particularmente
dañina si es una droga que tenemos ya
más o menos domesticada sin embargo ese
es el gran debate que en este momento
por ahora no sé en ese debate de la
legalización drogas más fuertes o más
intensas o más duras como seguirán como
la cocaína la harina tal vez por ahí lo
mencionan algunas personas pero más más
de manera aislada que realmente si es el
camino que estamos transitando el camino
hacia la legalización de la marihuana
tal vez solo tal vez ese mismo camino
nos lleve a la legalización de otras
drogas es que las cifras de consumo por
ejemplo en eeuu este año
la cifra de muertos por sobredosis de
diferentes tipos de drogas alcanzó 93
mil personas sólo en el año
2020 mientras que en el 2019 fue de 72
mil es decir el récord que han abatido
eeuu este año en cuanto a personas que
han fallecido por sobredosis como lo
decía usted de drogas mucho más fuertes
que en algunos estados estarán
debatiendo si aprobarlas o no pero pero
pero por ejemplo la marihuana con un uso
medicinal pues ya ha dado algunos pasos
importantes en los debates en los
diferentes sobre sobre esta cifra que
cada vez me permite algo
la mayor parte de esas personas que
usted acaba de mencionar murió por el
uso de drogas lícitas de drogas que no
están prohibidas que están reguladas en
tener un uso médico específico pero la
mayor parte de esas personas murió por
el uso de drogas lícitas de medicinas
digamos de medicinas que venden
transformado que vienen con prescripción
médica pero donde viene otra vez el tema
de la prevención y aprender a controlar
el consumo de las drogas que son ya por
prescripción médica que es otro tema
aparte le pregunto alberto en la ciudad
de lima sobre su opinión sobre la
legalización el uso el consumo la
comercialización la prevención ya a gran
escala como una forma tal vez de
informar más a la ciudadanía sobre el
consumo y sobre el manejo responsable de
esto y tal vez una forma de empezar a
mitigar el consumo como lo ve usted
no no yo no estoy de acuerdo con la
posición es decir las convenciones
naciones unidas tienen una lógica del
cannabis está permitido para usos
medicinales y científicos el cannabis
fumado la marihuana no solamente es
digamos contraproducente porque afecta a
las convenciones sino porque hace mucho
tiempo la ciencia ha dicho que cualquier
vegetal crudo ingresa al organismo es
malo es el cigarro y cigarrillo el
cannabis o la marihuana o como se llame
y además fíjese los modelos que ha
tratado de estandarizar está está
digamos liberalización está mal
concebida del cannabis han tenido los
primeros resultados que son realmente
complejos por ejemplo para países como
uruguay en los que el cannabis la
marihuana que pretendían ser legales
ahora están se ha abierto un mercado
negro de los cannabis de los canales del
cannabis o la marihuana paraguaya se
incrementado el riesgo
digamos de cáncer en los jóvenes el
consumo ha bajado promedio a los 20 años
y sobre todo
no no tenemos ninguna base científica
que asegure que el cannabis o quizás la
marihuana produzca efectos ciertos
medicinales en el organismo distinto de
aquellos productos que en muchas
legislaciones incluía la de colombia
perú y chile ha incorporado para el uso
de cannabis para fines medicinales como
los controles del estado y evitando lo
que llamamos en el derecho internacional
los riesgos de desviación es decir
aquellas plantitas que no quiere tener
en su casa y que lamentablemente pueden
servir para otros fines ilícitos este
que pueden afectar la seguridad de la
persona es un debate abierto pero yo me
remito en este momento estamos
trabajando mucho con la organización
mundial de la salud y con los datos
específicos que no aconsejan hacer esta
visibilidad para el uso recreativo del
cannabis bueno pues si tienen las dos
caras de este tema vamos llegando ya la
parte final del programa quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones sobre este tema
sobre que puede suceder que viene
siempre lo digo no tenemos la bola de
cristal para
y saber qué va a pasar en el futuro
sobre los temas que analizamos aquí en
el debate pero qué puede suceder en esta
lucha contra el narcotráfico contra la
violencia que viene acompañada con esta
industria millonaria y gigantesca a
nivel internacional la corrupción y todo
lo que viene acompañado sobre todo en la
región de américa latina francisco le
doy la palabra por favor muy puntual
para el cierre su conclusión
mi conclusión es simple
la legalización de la marihuana empezó
en
con los coches o dos en holanda
yo quisiera que alguien aquí ustedes sus
compañeros de panel me dijeran cuánto
tiempo cree que va a tomar que se
legalice
la cocaína
recreativa
esas no son soluciones
esa es la opinión de francisco tomen la
ciudad de villa de leyva en colombia
alberto en la ciudad de lima su
conclusión de este tema
pero muy muy preocupado por el
crecimiento y el tráfico ilícito de
cocaína
la cantidad de cocaína que está
ingresando a europa y eeuu casi se ha
duplicado en los últimos
12 meses eso por las parte los controles
evidentemente pero también por un
proceso que demuestra efectivamente la
ineficiencia de los estados y por otro
lado agosto concluyó esto es una
preocupación muy puntual hacia dónde va
este tema hacia las sustancias
sintéticas contra las drogas duras
venta ni lo el son digamos sustancias en
las que ya las mafias y los cárteles de
la droga están trabajando y que
representan un menor riesgo porque son
drogas más baratas el tráfico es mucho
más de digamos este asequible la
seguridad mayor para las organizaciones
que y señales de sobre todo la
posibilidad de poder ingresar a los
países masivamente cuatro productos de
xavier si ya tiene la historia para la
conclusión final es esa yo creo que lo
interesante de este proceso que como
bien anotada el profesor tommy comenzó
hace tanto tiempo
es que cada vez ha ido cogiendo ha ido
ganando impulso y llamó se rompió la
inercia con los coffeeshops que menciona
de holanda pero la inercia se ha ido
volviendo positiva digamos en el sentido
que la sociedad le tiene cada vez menos
miedo a la legalización si no el hecho
de que haya ya dos países de estados
soberanos que hayan legalizado uruguay
canadá el hecho de que haya varios
estados dentro de eeuu que hayan
legalizado también y bueno si digamos
por américa latina de europa encontramos
ejemplos también similares yo creo que
es un cambio de actitud de de una parte
de la población del mundo frente al tema
de la drogas yo creo que de alguna
manera se ha desmitificado por ahora la
marihuana esperaremos a ver yo creo que
la pregunta que plantea el profesor tumi
es de profundo calado se van a contraer
muy difícil de contestar porque el
agresivamente estamos hablando de una
droga frente a la que todavía si no sea
debatir eso le agradezco entonces a
francisco alberto de acesa por habernos
acompañado ustedes pensé que dejando sus
comentarios en las redes sociales sigan
con nosotros
[Música]